[Music]
from the decade that brought you the
sincerity of grunge the slacking of
generation x and the dursting of fred
comes another relic of a bygone era
a mid-budget studio comedy
clueless
welcome to la
okay west la all right like five blocks
of l.a not a taco in sight and meet cher
a rich girl with a two dollar brain full
of ten dollar words i've tried
everything to convince some of my
scholastic aptitude but i was brutally
rebuffed chill as if you through the
world of 90s teen culture
as seen through the eyes of a spoiled
rich girl
as seen through the eyes of a much older
screenwriter i don't want to be a
traitor to my generation and all but i
don't get how guys dress today okay
literal boomer
watches share matures from a plastic
doll who squeaks when she doesn't get
her way
[Music]
to a thoughtful woman who realizes the
error of her ways eventually ty is my
pal i don't begrudge her boyfriend i
really oh i wonder if they have that my
size
sorta lucy you know i don't speak
mexican
i'm not a mexican okay she doesn't
realize the error of her ways but she
does realize which boy she has a crush
on i love josh
it's a start
throw on your best plaid miniskirt and
join the popular click with cher's
bestie dion whose job is reacting to
stuff
[Music]
which considering stacy dash is some
whole deal the fewer chances to speak
the better i guess a lot of people in
the transgender community would then say
it is who i am okay then go go to the
bushes i don't know what to tell you
britney murphy is ty a transfer student
from the school of hard docs
but when cher transforms her into a
fellow hot mean girl you're a virgin who
can't drive it'll take all of eight
minutes before she apologizes and the
main conflict is diffused i'm so sorry
ty oh i'm really sorry there's
really not much of a plot to this flick
it's mostly just kids not realizing who
likes them great then ty you'll go with
summer and cherry you'll come with me
actually you could take will shirt to
cannon and that turns into benedict well
cause if girls did it what would guys do
to impress him
i don't know
do you see how he's falling in love with
me i mean look how he ignores every
other girl what am i gonna do with that
i don't want it
if high schoolers were really this
clueless we'd have way fewer seasons of
teen mom
don't forget to check out all the boys
like donald faison who used movie magic
to not look like a total uggo he had
fake braces famously in clueless yes
because they were trying to hide my
small teeth they shaved my head in
clueless because my hairline was
receding at 18. travis the only guy to
go to rehab for pot see i joined this
club and
then when he steps bob saget would not
approve
for marijuana
the always sensual wall is sean
and of course josh played by a
time-traveling paul rudd he shares love
interest who also happens to be her
ex-step-brother which the movie
desperately wants to make okay he's your
step-brother you are hardly even married
to his mother and that was five years
ago he is not your dad josh you are not
my brother uh-huh it's only a matter of
time before help josh i'm caught in the
washing machine but even if they aren't
related josh is still a college guy
dating a 16 year old girl and he looks
like paul ryde what happened dude did
every girl on campus see halloween six
[Music]
return to a more sophisticated era the
90s whatever mentos the freshman we
might get marky mark to plant a
celebrity tree in an adaptation of a
jane austen novel that skips most of the
social commentary cuts half the
characters and reworks a 500 page
narrative about class into a bubblegum
raw that turned all your assigned
reading into hollywood gold i'm not
saying julia styles owes alicia
silverstone a check but she owes alicia
silverstone a check
so get ready for a movie that captures
all the major trends of its decade like
box office hits about big old dummies
movies where a band with a horn section
randomly shows up and films about an
attractive actress pretending to be an
ugly duckling until they get a makeover
guys she's got glasses and a ponytail oh
look at that she's got paint on her
overalls
story
bro ryder a little dash will do you
donald failson
king of the beverly hill brother from
another mother so it's technically fine
relax
ty beau
guys and doll face
inconceivably sexy
the american education system
the only relatable character for anyone
over 25. hi daddy this is my friend ty
get out of my chair
and cher playing with her hair
[Music]
marvel's as if
okay how often do kids break out into
applause for each other in class was
that a thing that was never a thing
i put a lot of thought into picking this
comment
you know
you've got sponge i hate sponge
we're no strangers to love you know the
rules and so do i
bleed